this episode of legal eagle was made
possible by skill share learned to think
like a lawyer for free for two months by
clicking on a link in the description
various corners of the Internet have
suggested that President Trump is
somehow eligible to run for a third term
as president if we could put him on
another third term we got pundits have
jumped in and even the President himself
has suggested that he might be eligible
to get more than eight years in office
and then you want to really drive him
crazy go to hashtag third term
hashtag fourth term you'll drive them
totally crazy on multiple occasions and
if things keep going like hey going
we'll go and we'll do what we have to do
we'll do a three and a four and a five
of course we all learned in grade school
the presidents are limited to two terms
but is there a clever way around it
through perhaps impeachment or an end
run around the vice presidency well I
took a deep dive into this just because
I was curious and also terrified so you
don't have to so stick around and let's
figure out if there's a way to get more
than eight years in office as president
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because Jerry Falwell Jr
suggested the precedent Trump should add
two years to his presidency to make up
for the indignity of the Moller
investigation tweeting after the best
week ever for real Donald Trump no
obstruction no collusion New York Time
admits Barack Obama did spy on his
campaign the economy is soaring I now
support reparations Trump should have
two years added to his first term as
payback for time stolen by this corrupt
failed coup adding fuel to the fire
President Trump has sometimes speculated
on whether he could seek a third term
under the normal rules I'll be out in
2024 so we may have to go for an extra
term now the 22nd amendment limits a
president to two terms in office but
other presidents have also mentioned
serving a little bit longer during his
second term in 1987 Ronald Reagan said
maybe there should be a movement to
repeal the 22nd amendment and the
grandiosity is not limited to
Republicans Barack Obama said that he
thought he could be elected a third time
if he was eligible to run and all this
poses the question can a president serve
more than eight years in office now to
answer this question we have to go all
the way back to the Revolutionary War
the frame were seriously considered
making the office of presidency a
lifetime appointment and although they
didn't go through this plan they were
still reluctant to limit the president's
time in office as a result there were no
term limits in the version of the
Constitution that was ratified in 1788
the final version of the Constitution
ratified by the states made the office
of President a four-year position the
Constitution also created the office of
Vice President who would be the
president's successor in the event the
president could no longer serve of
course at the time the Constitution
specified that the person who finished
second in the presidential election
would win the vice presidency which was
a terrible idea that had horrible
repercussions that I'll probably cover
in another video now George Washington
was the only man ever seriously
considered for the first president of
the United States everyone assumed he
would win in a landslide and he did
twice and this is probably why many
people would have been happy to make
Washington president for life or an
elected King
luckily Washington was not okay serving
as president for life so when he ran he
privately assured people that he
wouldn't even serve a full four-year
term and he confided in Alexander
Hamilton that he thought he would only
serve for two years and get everything
straightened out and then
tire early and though Washington did run
for president twice and was elected
twice he decided to retire after the end
of his second term this move set a
precedent that lasted 150 years
Washington's retirement established a
custom that presidents followed until
the 20th century when Franklin Delano
Roosevelt was elected four times this is
why customs and laws are different a
custom is defined as a traditional and
widely accepted way of behaving or doing
something that is specific to a
particular Society place or time a
custom is an accepted norm that cannot
be enforced by law by contrast laws as
you know our systems of rules enacted by
a governing authority which can enforce
them through penalties and although most
presidents followed Washington's custom
of quitting after two terms some of them
tried for a third term ulysses s grant
ran for a third term in 1880 but lost to
James Garfield in the Republican primary
Grover Cleveland wanted a third term but
nobody wanted him now Teddy Roosevelt
served as vice president for James
McKinley and became president in 1902
after McKinley was assassinated now
t-dog was re-elected in 1904 and served
a full four-year term but in 1912 he ran
for a third non-consecutive term this
time as nominee of the Progressive Party
but he lost to Woodrow Wilson and Wilson
himself sought a third term but the
Democratic Party declined to nominate
him enter Franklin Delano Roosevelt
Franklin Roosevelt is the only person
elected for president for more than two
terms he succeeded at getting a third
term because he was president during a
time of unprecedented crisis for America
both the Great Depression and World War
two I will with God's help continue to
serve with the best of my ability and
with the fullness of my strength and of
course the rest is history Roosevelt was
elected to a fourth term in 1944
shattering the two-term custom at the
same time in Great Britain the war also
prompted a crisis of leadership in 1940
Britain amended its Parliament act which
had permitted a general election every
five years Parliament instead opted to
extend Winston Churchill's government
for five more years although the war was
Roosevelt's primary justification for
serving four terms not everyone was okay
with this development members of
Congress had been proposing term limit
motions for 140 years and they continued
to do so during Roosevelt's time in
office Roosevelt was in office from
1933 until 1945 Roosevelt died in office
just 11 weeks into his fourth term at
which time vice president Harry Truman
became present in 1947 Congress passed
the 22nd amendment which limited the
President to two four-year terms in
office it was finally ratified by the
states in 1951
now the 22nd amendment reads no person
shall be elected to the office of the
president more than twice and no person
who has held the office of President or
acted as president for more than two
years of a term to which some other
person was elected President shall be
elected to the office of President more
than once so the 22nd amendment says a
person can only be elected to be
President two times for a total of eight
years a person can serve for a maximum
of 10 years in a case of a president who
has ascended to the position as vice
president
that means it's theoretically possible
for a president to serve more than eight
years in office and a funny thing
actually happened while Congress in the
states were ratifying the 22nd amendment
limiting the number of years a person
could serve as president in fact
President Truman tried to win a third
term in 1952 the amendment didn't apply
to him since he was president when the
rule was passed because the second
Clause the 22nd amendment reads but this
article shall not apply to any person
holding the office of president when
this article was proposed by Congress
and shall not prevent any person who may
be holding the office of president or
acting as president during the term
within which this article becomes
operative from holding the office of
president or acting as president during
the remainder of such term so that gave
Truman the green light to run again but
Truman dropped his bid when he lost the
New Hampshire primary but of course
because you're watching this video right
now this amendment did not settle the
debate over term limits and Truman
wasn't the last President to consider a
third term so the question is what
happens if a president dies resigns or
is impeached the 22nd amendment has a
provision covering what happens if the
Vice President is forced to take over if
a vice president takes over because the
president dies is forced to resign or is
impeached then serves less than two
years then the person may serve for two
terms as president so for example if
Donald Trump were to die between now and
January of 2021 which seems unlikely
given that he's the paragon of Health
then Mike Pence could take over and run
for two terms as president serving out
roughly nine
as president but if the president dies
within two years of getting the office
like FDR who died within 11 weeks of
getting his fourth term then the person
who becomes president can only serve out
the remaining portion of that
president's term and seek re-election
once this would have been the situation
for Vice President Gerald Ford who
stepped in after President Nixon
resigned in 1973 Ford was only eligible
to be re-elected once he pardoned
Richard Nixon and lost the 1976 election
to Jimmy Carter and if you read the text
of the 22nd amendment it seems to have
some open questions for example does it
only prevent consecutive 4-year terms
can a person serve two terms return to
private life and then come back for a
third well the answer is no a president
cannot run for a third term after
skipping a term the amendment does
actually count the years served not
concurrent terms President Obama for
example has already served two terms and
eight years he cannot run for two more
consecutive terms later in his life or
even one more term later in his life now
some of President Trump supporters have
suggested that since he was impeached by
the house but not convicted in the
Senate he's eligible to run for two more
terms
the reasoning seems to be that
impeachment even without removal from
office nullifies his first term in
office so what impact if any does the
impeachment process have on a person's
ability to serve more than two terms
well the constitutional mechanism for
impeachment of a federal officer
including a president is set forth by
article 2 section 4 of the Constitution
which reads the president vice-president
and all civil officers of the United
States shall be removed from office on
impeachment for and conviction of
treason bribery and other high crimes
and misdemeanors the house did in fact
impeach President Trump don't listen to
anyone that says president Trump was not
impeached he was but the Senate did not
vote to convict and remove now the
Constitution in article 1 section 3 says
that the political consequences of
impeachment quote shall not extend
further than to removal of office and
disqualification to hold and enjoy any
office of Honor trust or profit under
the United States this means that if a
president is impeached and removed his
or her removal is the only political
consequence that they face now the
person may still face criminal charges
but that's not a political issue
although President Trump and his
supporters have argued that impeachment
nullifies an election
results this is definitely not the case
the only political consequence of
impeachment are removal and
disqualification which we'll get to in a
minute
impeachment doesn't operate to somehow
give the impeached person more time in
office so president Trump's time in
office is not nullified and he's still
bound by the 22nd amendment but what
would happen if a president was
impeached and removed could he or she
run for a third term then well the text
of article 1 section 3 seems to imply
that impeachment and conviction
disqualifies a person from running for a
high office later on in their post
impeachment life section 3 says that in
addition to removal the only political
consequence of conviction is quote
disqualification to hold and enjoy any
office of Honor trust or profit under
United States in 2015 the Congressional
Research Service explained that the
Senate would need to vote separately on
whether a person is disqualified from
future office in conjunction with the
impeachment trial stating although
removal from office would appear to flow
automatically from conviction on an
article of impeachment a separate vote
is necessary should the Senate deem it
appropriate to disqualify the individual
convicted from holding future federal
offices of public trust approval of such
a measure requires only the support of a
simple majority the report concluded
that even if a person is removed from
federal office they may still hold
another high office even president if
voters elect them the Senate has used
this procedure to decide whether other
federal office holders like judges
should be barred from future federal
offices if applied in the presidential
context the Senate could vote by a
majority to disqualify convicted present
from future office and there's an
additional wrinkle to disqualification
the Constitution isn't clear on which
public offices are those of quote
honored trust or profit you might
conclude that offices of senator
representative or president are such
offices or you can conclude exactly the
opposite this has not been settled or
even tested and the Congressional
Research Office is not necessarily the
final word that would be with the
Supreme Court presumably and maybe this
section of the Constitution merely means
a person is disqualified for federal
offices but is free to run for state
office but the bottom line is this if
the Senate convicts the president and
doesn't hold the crucial follow-up vote
on disqualification that person is free
to run for another office this may
include the presidency but only if the
person has not served
two full terms now that's all well and
good about the presidency but maybe the
vice presidency is an end run around the
22nd amendment so the first question is
do vice presidents even have term limits
and the answer is actually no vice
presidents are not subjected to term
limits they are treated the same as
members of Congress who also have no
limits on how long they can serve now
Mike Pence might never become present
but let's say he serves out eight full
years with President Trump and then
audible shudder Ivanka Trump becomes
president in 2024 could Mike Pence then
serve as her vice president the answer
is yes if Mike Pence wants to become a
kind of permanent vice president
president sitter there's nothing in the
Constitution that would prevent this
scenario in fact this has actually
happened twice George Clinton now not
that George Clinton and not that
Parliament it was George Clinton who was
the vice president for both Thomas
Jefferson and James Madison
similarly John C Calhoun served under
both John Quincy Adams and Andrew
Jackson so we know that vice presidents
can serve more or less indefinitely but
there's one hypothetical that certain
parts of the internet have really
glommed onto there might be one actual
way to get around the limitations of the
22nd amendment and that involves the
office of vice presidency it might be
possible for an ex-president to become
vice president and actually get more
time in office than they normally would
the first question is can an
ex-president even serve as vice
president and the answer is yes this
seems like the last thing any
ex-president would actually want to do
but a president is not barred from later
deciding to be the vice president no
former president has ever volunteered to
be vice president but there's nothing in
the Constitution that would stop it so
given that a former president can
actually be vice president one way to
potentially get around the 22nd
amendment would be for the president to
step down after their second full term
to then serve as someone else's vice
president and then for that president to
step down or resign or be impeached or
you know to just die at that point the
vice president would then attain the
office of presidency so in that
situation the president turned vice
president turned
again wouldn't be elected to the office
of president more than twice but they
would be able to serve out more than the
mere eight years and if you coupled that
with becoming president after starting
out as a vice president that could be
ten years already you could add almost
four years on top of that but hopefully
that situation never happens it's a
constitutional ambiguity and hopefully
we won't have to deal with that but I
for one don't understand why any
president would want to run for a third
term because being president is
temporary but being a youtube star is
forever any idiot can be president but
it takes more than being a stable genius
to be on YouTube and if you want to
start your own YouTube channel I'd
recommend Sorella more skill share class
YouTube success build an authentic
channel that's worth the follow Sorrell
shares her favorite tips and techniques
for building up a devoted online
following using examples from her own
past content and other Creators she
loves and remember youtubers are not
limited to two terms of four years each
by the 22nd amendment Skillshare is an
online learning community that has tens
of thousands of classes on everything
like design technology business music
you name it a yearly membership is less
than $10 per month the first 500 legal
eagles will get to three months of
Skillshare when you click on the link
below plus it really helps out this
channel just click on the link the free
premium membership gives you unlimited
access to must know topics so you can
improve your skills and learn new things
all free for two months improve yourself
now so you're not limited to just being
the President of the United States so do
you agree with my analysis leave your
objections in the comments and check out
my other real law reviews over here
where I talk about all of the legal
issues of the days like seven new nez's
lawsuits and presidential impeachment
just click on this playlist and I'll see
you in court